what's going on guys this is rob and i
don't care if anybody watches this video
i wanted to cover this so i've recently
been reading sweet tooth which actually
came out of vertigo and it's a netflix
series that's coming up this story is
amazing right it's probably one of the
coolest stories that i've read and it's
written by jeff lemire who actually drew
it as well which is kind of awesome i
don't know jeff lemire had pretty good
drawing chops this is
pretty cool but the cool thing behind
this is that this story is in a lot of
ways a post-apocalyptic story right so
the way this opens up is with the
the kind of main character we find out
his name here in a second but you get
this main character where he basically
has this kind of vision or this dream
that he's been experiencing
really multiple times where he finds
this man right this kind of strange man
he calls him like a big man
who's basically just looking at him with
just these cold looking eyes and then he
runs away as fast as he possibly can but
no matter how far he runs this guy keeps
getting closer and closer and then
ultimately the character wakes up right
and so from there
he actually ends up overhearing his
father now his father is a really
interesting character here and the
reason why is because the two of them
basically share a cabin or share a kind
of
homestead of sorts and he actually prays
to god every night now there are a few
things that are given to us here one of
the things
established right off the bat is that
this kid basically lost his mother and
his father is the only person that's
really there to take care of him but his
father's prayers for his son
are not really done just by an arbitrary
thing right he really believes them with
full conviction and he's always praying
that god keeps them protected
from the forces that are out there right
that god keeps them safe and it's kind
of a funny thing because what you end up
learning with this kid
is that he actually has antlers but the
other thing about this is his dad has
kind of told him stories
about years gone by right about how
society used to be before
this great collapse now the reality is
this place in which they live
is the nebraska state wilderness
sanctuary so the fact they're able to
kind of occupy this place with nobody
really knowing they're there it's kind
of a big testament to how far things
have gone
that and the fact you've got like you
know phone lines or power lines that are
just kind of collapsed
shows the society itself has more or
less fallen to the wayside right
whatever this is it is by all standards
of measurement a post-apocalyptic
wasteland the funny thing about this is
that as he's there he actually
ends up seeing this kind of candy bar
that's sitting out in the street and
where he initially goes to grab it he
kind of remembers a lesson from his
father which was
don't grab that stuff right don't eat
those candy bars those foods and things
like that that are out there
now with dinner with his father this is
where things get kind of interesting he
starts coughing up blood so right off
the bat we know that his father's not
long for this world now this is an
important thing because those of you
guys who are familiar with things like
the hero's journey
stuff like that you know that you kind
of have like the main hero who starts
out in what is more or less their safe
space
and they have kind of a mentor to a
degree but not officially right their
actual
mentor will come later on down the line
instead some kind of situation arises
that forces them to leave their home
in this instance this kid his safe space
is the house he lives in
under the protection of his father the
problem is that in the middle of all
this he kind of overhears the sort of
cracking sound and he sees another candy
bar that's sitting out there he
ultimately unwraps it and then starts to
eat it now when he gets back home and
his father realizes he's got a candy bar
in his hand and his and he's eating it
his father
immediately freaks out and that's when
you get the character's name which is
gus and what what happens here is gus
just kind of reveals well i found it out
there and i ate it and brought it back
and his dad's like you know where did
you get this from
but the fact that he has this candy bar
is a of huge concern for his father and
the reason why is because
no one's supposed to know they're there
right no one's supposed to to be aware
of the fact that they're there
more so than that there seems to be this
kind of thing where it's used as a trick
to basically lure people like gus
out right it's designed to either force
him to let his guard down or to keep him
distracted by what it is that he's
eating regardless of the situation
people know they're there now and that's
when his father says like you have to be
more careful right he talks about a kind
of illness and he says this illness
isn't me
and i know i'm going soon when the
question's asked like how long do you
have it's we don't know and that's when
you get what little information in this
opening story that you you get about the
mom which is
she seemed to fall pretty fast right she
went pretty quickly that for for people
who contract whatever this illness is
there's no definitive time frame on how
long
they will live for some people they last
weeks others they last months
presumably if you take an average people
end up lasting days it really depends on
seemingly a myriad of factors which
we'll find out later on but for the most
part we don't have a lot of information
here
but the whole purpose behind gus's
father really instilling in him this
philosophy of
you can't let people know that you're
here you can't let them know that you're
around
is really rooted in the purpose of just
keeping gus as safe as possible to keep
him away from this world but as we know
when it comes to us as young people
especially with teenagers you push
boundaries right when your parents say
don't do something you do it for no
other reason than the fact that you want
to know why you're not supposed to do it
right that curiosity gets the better of
you but regardless of the circumstance
you end up having a kind of period of
time that passes
where his father just kind of stopped
talking to god right it just kind of
kept to himself and the illness
basically took him now we're not really
given a definitive time frame here we
simply just know
some period of time happened and then
his father basically passed away
after which he buried him and then it
was just gus alone in the woods now at
that point he's actually visited by a
deer which is kind of wild but this is
important because this deer gets shot
and then in turn you have a couple
hunters who come out of nowhere and this
is when we start to get this kind of
greater explanation of what's going on
that it's not as though they were just
sort of traveling and came across a deer
and they have no knowledge of gus
nothing about a person walking around
with antlers uh it's one of the guys who
thought it was a hybrid and so
essentially
they have knowledge of not only gus but
people like gus this is kind of
exacerbated or expanded on when he says
like you know no like it was a kid it
was a kid with antlers right it was a
hybrid i saw him out here i know he was
here the other thing that kind of goes
on
is that while they end up basically
tracking down gus and gus runs away as
fast as he can and then is ultimately
cornered by these guys who really kind
of talk about how it is
it's one of these things where they can
sell him they can make a lot of money
off of him
there seems to be a kind of market for
kids like that now why that's the case
we'll find out later on down the line
instead what you end up getting is one
of these guys who's shot in the head and
ultimately gus is saved by a guy named
jeopard which is kind of an interesting
and bit of a unique name
it's one of these funny things where
jeopard really kind of gets the trust of
gus by virtue of the fact that he saved
his life and jeopard here is really
presented us
as kind of a grizzled and pretty
experienced guy right he's kind of
hardcore but it's one of these things
where he really is seem to be looking
out for
gus when he kind of says like i've never
seen one that was like part deer before
and one of the funny things that happens
is he kind of asks him he's like how
long have you been here right how long
have you have you experienced all this
and when he's like you know where's your
mom where's your dad the reality is he
says like my mom's dead she went to
heaven and my dad only died not too long
ago
and so we kind of asked him he's like
how long have you been in this place and
this kid says like you know i've i've
been here my whole life and when he asks
how old are you he says my dad told me
that last year i was nine and that's
when jeopard kind of hits in and says
that's not possible
people like you didn't start popping up
until after this illness started
spreading across presumably the world
and this didn't start until seven years
ago so you're telling me that you
predate this illness
there's a lot of intrigue and mystery
going on here of course as you guys can
tell
we're far from getting the full picture
but he asked him did your dad ever tell
you about a place called the preserve
and when when gus says no his response
is it's a safe place right for
people like you that are half human half
animal but basically people are out
there hunting for you people are trying
to find you they're trying to kill you
or at the very least trying to sell you
so they can make money off of you like
the preserve is a safe place for people
like you that keeps you kind of hidden
away
now the cool thing about jeopard and
that's what's so interesting here is on
one side
you could say he's suss right like in
like a conservative estimate this guy is
suss as hell right but on the other hand
he really presents himself as a guy who
saved the life of gus
and in doing that he basically earns
gus's trust to a degree when he
initially tells gus
you need to come with me gus's immediate
response is no right like i don't i'm
not going with you i don't know you like
why would i go with you and so he's like
fine he throws him a slingshot back and
says good luck kid right like i don't
really care whether you come with me or
not and so that right there is kind of
our first indication that it's not as
though jeopard is
out for gus right it's not as though
he's basically a hunter who killed off
competition
instead he's just kind of like a seems
more or less like a wanderer right or
some kind of a
of a vagrant just kind of roaming around
and doing his thing but then gus seeks
him out and the reality is
gus is not really in a position to where
he's capable of taking care of himself
right he in a lot of ways
needs a kind of mentor here he needs
somebody to kind of keep an eye on him
somebody to watch over him
so guts can learn the ropes of how to
take care of himself and then when the
time presents itself he can kind of
again
graduate out into this greater tribe and
basically make it in the world on his
own and so as a result where he kind of
had the dream of this big man who seemed
exceedingly scary
instead of running he actually goes with
him and so while the two of them kind of
taken aside
and just sort of relax for the night
just because of the fact that it seems
like traveling at night is not really
the best thing for you to do
instead jeopard kind of gives us this
little bit of a
of an explanation on what's going on we
don't get a full-on explanation here
instead it's really more of a tease or
something like that but when he asked
him did your father ever tell you how
all this started
the response of god says well you know
he said that god came and took most
people up to heaven and the ones that
stayed here well they have it real hard
and they have to pray really hard so
they can go to heaven too right it's
almost kind of given as like a rapture
that's almost the way that that gus's
father presented it to him that the
faithful were taken to heaven
and those who were left behind have to
demonstrate their their conviction and
their belief
and acceptance of of god and jesus in
order to actually get into heaven
when the second kind of rapture comes
around and the response to this guy is
that's the dumbest thing i've ever heard
right that's not what happened at all
instead like everybody got sick right
everybody got really really really
really sick
and ultimately everybody here in the
world is infected right so seemingly
whatever this is is an environmental
thing right you can't necessarily escape
you can't go to an underground bunker
and be safe or possibly you could but so
long as you're on the surface
you're infected right which basically
means for all of humanity the clock's
ticking right there's only a matter of
time before everybody dies that's
exactly what jeopard said right like
everybody's going to die is only a
matter of time before they do
in the end they're all just trying to
outlive it the only exception are you
guys
you hybrid kids who for whatever reason
are immune to this infection you don't
you're not you're not infected by it you
won't die from it it just
exists out there and for you it's no
different than how it was for us as
humans before all this started in the
first place and so there's no real
definitive answers that are given by
jeopard but he does kind of reveal a bit
of a harder streak when he says like
god has nothing to do with anything
that's going on here and i don't want to
hear anything more about how god made
all this stuff happen right like and
it's one of these things where he kind
of presents himself as a guy who is in
some ways a realist but also a bit of a
cynic right in the sense that it's just
this is the way in which the world is
right there's no possibility it could be
anything other the world is hard and
it's tough we're all going to die
and that's just the way that it is right
it's kind of ruthless and a little bit
rough here but in the middle of all that
while jeopard is trying to catch some
sleep you end up having these humans who
kind of show up with like animal masks
on right so right off the bat we've got
tribalism right basically humans
breaking down
into smaller tribes and that kind of
makes sense right if you read any sort
of philosophical or even
a political book that focuses on what
humanity would be like during the
collapse of a society
right if the u.s government just
completely collapsed and there was no
standing military anymore
right or anything along those lines say
for example you had some scenario at the
tv show jericho where like nuclear bombs
were detonated in like 21 major u.s
cities whatever it is
it's just like the collapse of society
what you would have is
basically warlords and petty strongmen
that would rule
small pockets of society across the u.s
and those individuals who lacked the
conviction or confidence to basically
handle themselves adequately
would pursue those petty warlords and
strongmen and they would look to them
for a measure of protection following
that it really kind of falls into like
hobby and philosophy
in a state of nature or kind of a lack
of any organized government when it's
sure those petty warlords and those
those strong men would abuse their power
but those individuals who are being
ruled over would accept that as the
price they pay for the protection they
get so again it's it's kind of an
interesting concept and so what you end
up getting is one of these guys who
manages to snatch up gus
and then basically take off with him of
course jeopard comes to the rescue and
shoots this guy in the head and then
essentially succumbs to his wounds right
now in the sense that he dies he really
just kind of passes out but ultimately
gus ends up being the one to save him
when they come across a little bit of a
barn or a kind of shed and in the time
that he had with his father his father
taught him how to grow crops his father
taught him how to
how to deal with wounds and injuries
essentially all kinds of survival skills
he would need
in order to make it on his own if he
were to ever sustain an injury or if he
were to ever find allies and had to tend
to their injuries and that's exactly
what happened here right that while
jeopard is kind of passed out and
succumbing to his injuries or at least
you know coping with his injuries as
best he can
that gus ends up sort of finding a house
off in the distance and it just sort of
goes through and raids the place and
finds like some cans of food and
different things along those lines one
of the other things he finds here
is there's a little kid upstairs in
their bedroom who's basically died and
so what this does is it seems to point
to the idea that because the parents are
nowhere to be found the kid was
abandoned right and that was it but this
kid was basically just
left alone the other part of this is
this kid is essentially reading the
story of bambi the alternative to that
possibility is their parents died before
they did and then they ultimately
succumbed to the sickness and then die
too the reason why i say that is because
as you guys know a hallmark of the story
bambi
is that bambi's mom dies and bambi's
ultimately taken by his father and then
raised but that doesn't really seem to
happen here regardless of how you slice
it
gus ends up having this dream once he
falls asleep where he's met by the
arrival
of a couple different animals and one of
them comes in the form of what he
imagines this little kid would be like
if he was actually bambi
along with a with another animal and
it's one of these things where they
literally talk to him and say like we
don't have much time right like you have
to listen very very carefully you have
to take
as much food as you can from that house
and run away
and you have to go back to the woods
don't go back to your house in the woods
but you have to go back to the woods and
that's where
gus is kind of like no like mr jefford
is looking out for me right he's keeping
me safe he's doing just like my dad did
and the response of of dandy here is no
gus like
it's not safe and he's an exceedingly
bad man
and there'll be even more bad men soon
so you have to get out as fast as you
can and they literally tell him
run right like run as fast as you
possibly can but ultimately that doesn't
really happen instead you end up having
gus who wakes up from his dream
and then in turn he leans a little
further into jeopard by just kind of
being like okay like this guy is keeping
me safe this guy's protecting me right
like why should i be worried about a man
who's protecting me from like all these
different bad men who were out there but
ultimately you end up coming into this
kind of smaller town of sorts and when
they gather there's a huge section of
town that's kind of cordoned off where
you have like all these dead bodies
right like all these all these folks who
have just kind of been piled up and and
just sort of left there and that was it
so what this really kind of shows us is
like society was collapsing
exceedingly fast right like people were
dying very very quickly so much so that
there wasn't a whole lot of time to
dispose of the bodies or anything along
those lines but they end up stumbling
across
what looks like a kind of apartment
building of sorts and gus notices
there's a person up there and so what
they end up doing is getting into this
place and there's a girl who basically
says like my name's becky you know
what's your name
and so seemingly she looks like she's a
kind of prostitute or something and then
they're kind of taken by surprise by the
guy who's more or less running the
brothel
along with his wife and then they intend
to basically kill and rob rob shepard
and that's kind of the crazy thing is
because once they also realize gus
is there they're like okay we can do a
lot with this right like we can we can
like sell this kid to a militia camp we
can do pretty much anything
and that's one of the things where
they're kind of like we'll take the kid
off your hands and we have a lot to
trade right and kind of offers the girls
who are there not only that this girl
becky was wearing like fake rabbit here
she's just a regular human but the
reality of this
is that this husband and wife
essentially have taken these girls we
don't know if they were kidnapped or
whatever the case is but they've taken
these girls and they present them as an
offer to somebody if they have something
to trade or at the very least use them
as bait and a distraction
against people in order to essentially
take them away in order to take away the
belongings they have and the the things
they need to survive
more or less like setting up a trap the
funny thing about that too is that you
actually have gus who's like no no you
have to let us leave
mr jefford is going to take me to the
sanctuary and that's where becky's like
no that's not real that's a made up
place like what are you talking about
and
the wife here is just like kill him
right just just kill him and be done
with it that's when this man looks at
jeopard and he's like oh you're taking
him to the preserve it looks like i'm
not the only businessman here right like
that's apparently what you're doing here
and that's what he says like what's
stopping me from taking this kid
off to you know the preserve myself and
kind of calling it a day so
again all these hints and all these
indications are coming in this direction
that like to preserve
is not a very good place but jeopard
really kind of hits it off and says look
like do you think you can pull that
trigger faster then i can
i can literally kill you right or yank
that gun out of your hand or something
like that are you that quick and so
we're kind of dealing with this idea
that jeopard is pretty hardcore
and so ultimately they they they don't
call us bluff they're like okay like
they they buy into it they're like just
let them go right let them go let's call
it a day and so jeopard
ends up leaving alongside gus the
problem with this is the girls almost
kind of like beg to a degree like like
save us right like please like get us
out of this place and gus really shows
this kind of moral compass here when he
tells jeopard like no
we can't just leave here like i know you
want to but we can't just leave here
and then upstairs they hear one of the
girls being slapped around by presumably
the guy
and so because of this jeopard heads
back upstairs literally with his rifle
tells one of the girls to be quiet and
then just
takes it to this guy and literally helps
him understand his place in the bigger
picture right just like
smashes this guy's head right just beats
this guy to death with the butt of his
rifle and then where he goes to kill the
girl one of the other girls is like
no let us be the one to do it right so
they just like blow this girl's head off
and the whole time it's being watched by
gus and so gus is getting a lot of
experiences
that he's never seen before but the
other part of this is that when jeopard
goes to leave
one of the girls is like no you have to
stay you have to protect us we can use a
guy like you so again
people who aren't necessarily capable of
protecting themselves flocking to what
they perceive to be
stronger individuals right just the
nature of a collapsed society and even
in an organized society that's still
kind of the case right i mean
technically they call it hypergamy but
it's essentially the exact same concept
just in a post-apocalyptic landscape
but the important thing is that
ultimately jeopard is like no right
we're not staying here right like
jeffrey you know and that's when gus is
kind of like no
he's going to take me to the preserve
everything's gonna be okay and this
girl's like okay yeah sure like the
preserve right you'll see it's not a
good place right you better you better
watch your back the preserve that's
no preserve like where you're going
that's not what you think it is and so
ultimately you end up having gus
and uh and jeopard who basically just
race as fast as they possibly can to
where the destination is supposed to be
right so this preserve itself they end
up coming across a couple individuals or
really kind of a trap that's set up by
people who are looking to like you know
rob others and different things like
that the kind of stuff you would
normally expect to see
in some kind of a of a you know
post-apocalyptic landscape
in the process the horse is shot gus
goes flying off bumps his head and kind
of knocks him unconscious and so with
the horse basically being dead
jeopard picks him up and then walks the
rest of the way and ultimately ends up
getting him directly to the preserve
the problem is the place looks shady at
best it looks like a concentration camp
it's not enormous it's pretty small but
you've got like guards and things like
that
it's not really a preserve in the
traditional sense right people who are
basically being kept in captivity behind
a fence and so when that happens when
when
basically jeopard shows up and says hey
like tell him what's going on
right like get a hold of it tell him
it's jeopard then in turn once abbott
approaches and starts talking to him
then he's like okay
like this is cool you know like you
brought us a kid he said he's nine years
old okay this works man this kid will
make a great specimen so
obviously the preserve is not what we
thought it was and jeopard is not a good
guy
jeopard is he's a hunter like literally
he was killing other guys who were
hunters he was killing the competition
and literally
the whole thing behind this is he gets
some kind of huge amount of payment and
he basically just
sells gus to the preserve now the crazy
thing about that is in this place
it's a place of nightmare and torment
this is a horrible place to be in
and gus is going is learning right off
the bat you can't trust
everybody it doesn't mean that people
themselves cannot be trusted but it's
like the movie the italian job people
are good it's the devil inside them that
you don't trust that's kind of the thing
here right jeopard kind of revealed his
colors
and played on the ignorance and the
inexperience of gus
that gus had never really been out there
in the world gus didn't know that you
couldn't really trust people the words
of his father were accurate right that
in this post-apocalyptic landscape there
were only two kinds of people those who
were self-serving and those who die
you don't want to be the ones who die
right you cannot trust people
stay in the woods do not leave you have
everything you need to learn how to
survive here to make it in this place i
taught you everything and the first
thing gus did
was betray the rules of his father and
the pricey pace is he's being sold to uh
to basically a preserve
what is an effect a giant place of
experimentation with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section i love it and i
will catch you all later
peace